you don't want to see while you're
sitting in the plane anyone fixing the
wing screwdriver but you especially
don't want to see it when it looks like
this
watch
heing now he's just spreading them
out did
he first of all as a casual viewer who
is not at all an expert in aircraft
engineering or any other kind of
engineering it did appear to me that he
removed the screw from one hole and then
screwed it into a different hole that's
what she said and and maybe I'm
misinterpreting what we just watched
there hopefully I am I must also say
that it's rather disturbing to see the
guy using a regular Philips screwdriver
I guess I always assume that they use
very powerful like industrial grade
electric screwdrivers that you can't
even find at at at lows